こんにちははじめ社長です皆さんさらんアップしてますでしょうか
はいこちらのこれでございますん
森わーお料理とかでもうまつげなく使われるんですけども野菜とか果物の鮮度をキープ
するために高ラッピングし2やつでございます
まあ一般的なお姉取りにくいやつですねまあ一般的にはそういう潮流に使われるんです
けどもまぁ
ユーチューバー御用達のドッキリ道具でございますよこれでさあ来いつまらん時に
ブービーことに生き餌ティっ路村ドッキリ
ああああああ
だめだというわけで私は思いましたあなたを切りの何が生ぬるいかというと例えば
わけです1の女ってそんなにバカじゃないっすよ
さすがにサランラップが張ってあったらどう有名なお分かりますしちょっとね成功する
可能性が非常に低い私は断言します youtube に上がっているサランラップ
ドッキリのほぼ
98%はヤラセです
間違いないでしょそんな中何ぞ朽木したくないんで今回はサランラップを使ってもう
確実に成功するかずもっと驚くドッキリを仕掛けると思いますが付けて
車衝突ドッキリでございます
すごい避難ドッキリの説明をしましょう今から何な高社交の入り口に貼っと貼りますて
ターゲットにクレーマーちょっと車こいで磨いて釣って来バックするんですけども車
からだったら多分3アップ全然気づかないと思うんですよ人間の眼で見るより多分車を
通してあのバックモニターとは言えば全然たのかわかんないと思うんでどれで
ターゲットその車をバックスーツ
して何もないって安全確認しながらいくんですけどもとなぜか作ってしまう感覚に襲わ
れ
行為これであればもうタラップがバレる可能性もかなり低いですし直接当たるんじゃ
なくて車を通して当たるんでなんかを巻セットいけないヤバさんって車をぶつけて
しまったという恐怖方と切り的にはいろんな用途がすべて上をいってるんでこれ起こさ
なラップ
大木でほぼないかなと思っていうぐらいでございますが早速仕掛けにできましょう
そういう水をはって行こうと思います綺麗にハットが一番で薄くきれいにここに貼ろう
と思います
[音楽]
re おおおおおおおおおおおおおん
ポッっと見えるもんでも
では ea 見えない映画 a だねこれあれだね光の影響で気がすんだよ
外からとめっちゃなかったですけど内側からるってこれは考えている
まずようー do
もうちょっと京都たがありますよね
言えないと
なにみえないヶ月けど
つか見えないでしょちょっとついてダウン
ん
h が見えるへの影響なのかはいというわけでですね内側だったらわかんないんです
けど外側だとやっぱりちょっと反射が山崎でめっちゃわかりませんまあでも多分車の
バックモニターボスだとわからないと思うんでろうそくターゲットに仕掛けていき
ましょうって on target ように行けますウードゥー
拉致艦これなんかねー
大家さんがなんか車移動せって言ってるなぁ
うんそっち tj
他の映画マイ認めてるよぷっ
ん
[音楽]
なった
背中た伸ばさないから取れず
言わせの後ろにゴースのそう私との間ができたこのはバックで入ってもらって
異なる待つん
というものですよ甘くて指入れてあもう目視で得たが気合で目視でい
北京なんですよメンズ第二軍のスーパーダビングダビング
ですねぇーよああ優勝でしょ
よいしょあのこれ処分こそそこでか戻すぞ
優勝の空自はコマ数リングを弄るよ
[音楽]
ん
何がなるんです
なぬ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
ん
なにこれなにこれ
はいというわけですーっ
それじゃあテレまあ2ちょうど皿
見えない壁ドッキリでした
私はマークにゃーんの空なく弱